a time of really high inflation it is
really difficult isn't it for the
government to balance the books in this
way and to not make the economic
situation for the whole country worse
well it's the problem of the
government's own making last month so
the largest decrease in real pay since
records began we've had 12 years now of
conservative government freezing pay or
reducing pay in real terms and indeed
take-home pay
today is still just about where it was
or less than in 2008 and then when you
have an inflation crisis that we have at
the moment that the chickens certainly
come at home to roost what the
government are essentially saying is
that the
inflation crisis that they have
partially created in this country should
be on the backs of the working people of
this country who haven't had a pay rise
in a very very long time with real wages
continuing to decrease so it can't be
the case as well that um it would fuel
inflation because we don't have any
growth in this country we have this huge
stagnation problem and we can't have
huge uh inflation and no economic growth
but we do in this country and and the
government needs to try and find a way
of sorting this out they could
immediately take that off fuel of course
to try and solve the problem with the
energy in terms of the contribution
that's making to inflation and pull out
every single to try and resolve this
problem rather than ministers sitting
back in their offices saying none of
this is our problem we'll just let the
unions and the employers fight this out
and it can't be the case i spoke to a
cleaner of the trains in edinburgh
waverly
on monday when i was traveling down to
westminster who doesn't even get sick
pay he went all the way through covet
cleaning the trains he's continuing to
work to clean the trains and doesn't get
sick pay those terms and conditions
can't surely be what this conservative
government wants to try and promote in
this cost of living crisis era
and mass back to you of course we're
having this whole row about wages and
the government is saying you know we all
have to be careful but at the same time
a triple lock on pensions why should
those older members of society be
protected against the economic
impact that the rest of us are having to
feel
pensioners particularly hard hit and
they are of course on uh fixed incomes
the uh the comparison between uh someone
in work and a pensioner is not a perfect
one i know you're not suggesting it is
but i do think we need to be careful
about making about pretending that
pensioners are somehow wealthy the
proportion of pensioners in poverty
often receiving pension credit as well
is something that is rightly addressed
through the triple lock that's why it
was uh in the conservative manifesto and
the suspension of it during covid while
it was the right thing can't be a
permanent thing because otherwise you'll
see more and more pensioners a huge risk
of going into poverty in a way that
isn't
seen for people who are in work so i do
think we have to fight different battles
with different tactics and making sure
that pensioners are protected against
the current set of circumstances is the
right thing making sure that the
railways are protected both against
the increasing lack of use of technology
and making sure that they are fit for
the future is a different battle and we
should fight it with different means
sarah only for the lib dems what what
would the liberal democrats do in terms
of this would would you still be keeping
the triple lock on pensions would you be
protecting pensioners above other
members of
society well i think what's important is
that we have to look at the impact that
inflation is having right across the
whole of uh society every household is
facing rising bills but the working age
population in particular have just seen
a big hike in their national insurance
contributions what we've been calling
for is for that national
insurance increase to be reversed but
what we also want to see for all
households uh is a decrease in uh in vat
to reduce it from 20 to 17 and a half
percent and we think that could put 600
pounds back into the pockets of every
household in the country and that would
make a real difference in terms of
fighting inflation so those are the
things that we are uh really concerned
about
okay sarah only from the lib dems in
murray for the labour party and matt
warman for the conservatives thank you
all so much for giving us your thoughts
ahead of prime minister's questions uh
let's get the thoughts somebody with his
ear close to the ground sam coates our
deputy political editor is in
westminster what do you think we're
going to see in in prime minister's
questions we saw last week kirsten
really just pushing on the cost of
living not being distracted by other
stuff that was going on do you think
this is something we're going to see
again today
i think we'll edge sideways on that
debate uh jane across to strikes it's a
funny old week in westminster there are
what by any uh yardstick would be
massive uh events going on we've got
these two by-elections tomorrow we've
got this uh major reform of how human
rights legislation uh is incorporated
into british law and treated by the
court uh and then we've got the issue of
the s the strikes but it's actually in a
funny way a lower key week in
westminster than some of the more recent
ones there's no vote of confidence
there's no epic westminster event and in
fact because of those rail strikes a lot
of uh mps not actually in parliament
this week they've decided to work from
home uh difficult of course as it is to
come from far flung bits of the country
uh into westminster when there are these
three days
of strikes um the strikes i suspect
kirsten will want to get on the front
foot when it comes to the public sector
strikes uh the rail strikes that have
blighted so many people's lives this
week uh why might he do that well the
strikes pose problems for the government
in terms of how much money they're
willing to let network rail offer the
rail unions but they've also been posing
uh problems for the labour party
kierstarma a couple of nights ago made
clear he didn't want members of his team
appearing on the picket line he doesn't
want labour to be too closely associated
with the industrial action of the rmt uh
for fear that unpopular strikes would
damage the brand uh of the labour party
but then again labor is the party
traditionally of the workers it has
historic ties to the trade unions and so
that stance has upset some members uh
four pps's which the kind of junior bag
carrier role uh attached to shadow
secretaries of state well uh four people
uh uh in the front bench team uh defied
kierstarm's instructions appeared on the
um picket line uh and i'm sure that uh
boris johnson would use that um uh to
suggest that there's some kind of test
of kiersten's authority which is all why
i suspect that uh mr stanley himself
will want to get on the front foot on
that topic
and make clear exactly what his line on
strikes is it's worth listening very
closely when kirsten does stand up to
the language that he uses because he's
until now tried a rather kind of careful
tightrope act he says
he doesn't want to see this industrial
action it's a mark of failure of the
government the government should have
got round the table but he doesn't echo
uh the position of the conservative
party of the government of boris johnson
in simply saying the strikes are wrong
you heard uh earlier uh shadowfront
ventures basically saying look we
respect the right to strike uh but not
either endorsing it explicitly or
condemning it explicitly uh kistama of
course sometimes uh faces the challenge
that he's uh something of a blank canvas
and i suspect that on this issue uh it's
quite hard for him uh to carve out a
distinctive line that doesn't either
upset uh too many voters or perhaps
those uh in his own party with
traditional links uh close links to uh
the trade union certainly those on the
left pushing kirsten to go further
yesterday so i think that's one of the
big things uh that we're going to be
seeing there might be some questions
about dominic rams new plans to overhaul
human rights in the long term i suspect
that plan will put britain on a course
to collision course effectively uh with
the uh
strasbourg uh human rights court uh
sam's gonna get to pause the prime
minister's on his feet
outstanding contribution to british
society and will also be a permanent
place of reflection mr speaker as part
of armed forces week i was delighted to
host a reception yesterday in downing
street members across the house are
immensely proud of our armed forces and
we thank them and their families for
their service to our country and mr
speaker i know the house will welcome
the deal that we've signed with moderna
which will see them build new facilities
in the uk including around a billion
pounds of new investment in research and
development uh mr smee mr speaker
supporter had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others in addition to my
duties in the science i shall have
further such meetings later today and i
will be traveling thereafter to chogham
in rwanda i will then be attending the
g7 leaders summit and the nato summit mr
speaker so full budget of news for you
there
chriselle mall thank you mr speaker can
i associate myself with the prime
minister's comments in relation to the
armed forces uh and the
comments
prime minister
have has he ever considered the
appointment
of his current spouse
to a government post or to any
organization yes in one of the royal
households be honest prime minister yes
or no yes or no
mr speaker i i know why the uh the party
opposite wants to talk about uh
non-existent jobs uh in the in the media
mr speaker because they don't want to
talk about what's going on in the real
world
i'm proud to say i'm proud to say
actually uh that we now have
620 000 people more in payroll
employment than before the pandemic
began which would never have been
possible if we listened to the right on
the german
[Applause]
[Music]
the uk is the global leader in social
outcomes contracts they can deliver
public services in an array of areas
from health care mental health care
employment education and development aid
according to big society capital every
one pound the government has spent in
this way has delivered 10 pounds in a
further economic social and fiscal value
including three pounds in direct savings
to government does my right honourable
friend agree that the time is right for
the government to redouble its focus on
these outcomes-led commissioning
my honourable friend is absolutely right
to champion this type of approach which
makes a real difference to uh people's
lives people suffering uh from mental
health issues helping them to find a
route back into to work and that's why
we are commissioning more uh initiatives
through uh such funds as the life
chances fund uh helping those people in
society who face uh the biggest barriers
to have happy and productive lives
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kia starman
thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister in his comments about
windrush uh and can i pay tribute to
everyone who is serving and has served
in our armed forces
can i also pay tribute to everyone
standing for election tomorrow
in particular the plucky conservative
candidate for wakefield
he's standing even though his own
colleagues think he's so useless they
held a vote of no confidence in him
[Applause]
just the prime minister
just
[Applause]
does the prime minister hold any
personal interest
in seeing if the public will vote for a
tory that even his own side don't think
is up to it
well mr speaker i have absolutely no
doubt uh that the people of this country
and the people of wakefield people of
tibetan and hollister would much rather
vote uh for a solid conservative
government
for a labour party they're enablers and
acolytes in the liberal democrats mr
speaker the chameleons the karma
chameleons of british politics are when
that when the leader of the labour party
hasn't even got the gumption mr speaker
to speak out against the rail strikes
to the people in the north of this
country up and down this
absolutely unbelievable silence from the
leader of the labour party mr speaker
[Applause]
he's obviously not been to wakefield
recently
he's crashed the economy he's put
everybody's tax up the last tour he's
sent up to wakefield being convicted of
a sexual assault that's not much of a
pitch prime minister
talking of people not up to the job
whilst the transport secretary spends
his time working on his spreadsheet
tracking the prime minister's
unpopularity
thousands of families have had their
holiday flights cancelled it takes
forever to renew your driving license or
passport and now we've got the biggest
rail strike in 30 years
[Applause]
both sides let's calm down we've only
just started
the problem is he'll come forever and
nobody wants i sure you
whoever's speaking or asking questions
here's stammer
if he's genuine about preventing strikes
will the prime minister tell this house
how many meetings he or his transport
secretary have had with rail workers
this week to actually stop the strikes
mr speaker this is this is the
government that loves the railways that
invests in the railways not not 96
billion pounds we're putting into the
integrated railway plan building not
just i'm proud of bill crosstrail by the
way mr speaker and we're going to build
northern powerhouse rail but what we've
got to do is modernize our railways and
it is a disgrace when we are planning to
make sure that you don't have ticket
offices that sell fewer than one ticket
every hour mr speaker but he yesterday
had 25
labour mps
out on the picket line
out on the picket line to find the
constructions
i want to hear the prime minister's
answer even if you don't
i think you ought to show some respect
for the prime minister prime minister
out on the 25
and and the shadow
deputy leader out on the picket line uh
mr speaker backing the strikers mr
speaker while we back the strivers
mr speaker i'm surprised he's giving me
advice about my team if i do need advice
let's say about a hundred thousand pound
job at the foreign office i will ask him
for recommendation
and there you mr speaker
there you have it the prime minister of
this country and his transport secretary
haven't attended a single meeting held a
conversation or lifted a finger to stop
these strikes
but i did know that on monday they did
find time to go to a lavish ball where
the prime minister sold a meeting with
himself for 120 000 pounds
if there's money coming his way he's
there
[Applause]
he's nowhere to be seen
so rather than blame everyone else why
doesn't he do his job get round the
table and get the trains running
mr speaker
we are making sure that we do everything
we can to prevent
these strikes as he knows it is up to
the railway companies to negotiate and
that is their job uh we've spent 16
billion pounds looking after the
railways mr speaker throughout the
pandemic that's cost every household 600
pounds and at the same time we know why
he takes the line he does we know why he
won't condemn the strikes we know why
even now he hasn't got the gumption to
call out his his mps who are going out
on uh going out to support the pickets
mr speaker
the reason his authority is on the line
in this matter is that they take
they take 10 million pounds from the
unions mr speaker that's the fee that's
the fee that the learning gentleman
opposite is receiving for the case he is
failing to make
[Applause]
he can't help himself there's a huge
problem facing the country and all he's
interested in doing is blaming everyone
else
can't he hear the country screaming at
him get on with your job
whilst he blames everyone and anyone
working people are paying the price
this week his treasury minister said
there's a society-wide responsibility
for people to take a pay cut
at the same time his chief of staff is
trying to change the law to get bankers
bonuses increase
so come on
come on
only one of them could be right
is it his treasury minister who says
every worker needs a pay cut
or is it his chief of staff who says
every banker needs a pay rise
actually mr speaker under this
government five million public sector
pay apartments have to work is getting a
pay rise mr speaker we've increased the
living wage by a thousand pounds uh
we've increased universal credit so that
people get a thousand pounds more
thanks to the fiscal firepower that we
have mr speaker we're putting 1200
pounds more into
every one of the 8 million most
vulnerable households in the country
that is what we can do because of the
tough decisions that we have taken mr
speaker but meantime what we're also
trying to do is cut the cost of
transport which is a big part of
people's weekly outgoings by reforming
our railways that's what we're trying to
do but he's standing with the strikers
mr speaker and lifting the cost of
transport for everybody that's the
reality
[Applause]
his chief of staff says that removing
the capital bankers bonuses is in his
words reflective of our new approach
pay rises for city bankers pay cuts for
district nurses that's the new approach
mr speaker i didn't see that on any
leaflets in wakefield
but this hasn't come from nowhere
because according to the financial times
on the 7th of june last year the prime
minister was directly lobbied for the
cap to be lifted
rather than help working people he's
rolled over on bankers bonuses
[Music]
[Applause]
uh mr speaker
what we're actually doing is putting
thanks to the decisions we've taken we
are putting more money into the pockets
of people up and down the country
1200 pounds more
for the 8 million most vulnerable
households and the reason the reason we
can do that mr speaker is because we
took the tough decisions necessary to
come out of the pandemic faster than any
other european country that's why we
have unemployment at or near record lows
uh mr speaker none of that would have
been possible if we had listened to him
and we have more people now in payroll
employment than we had before the
pandemic began that is what the british
people know and that is what this
government is going to continue to
deliver
[Music]
15 tax rises high tax
low wages low growth that sums his
government up
working people paying more tax under
this government and now they're told to
take a pay cut
he's having meetings about increasing
bankers bonuses
but he can't find time for a single
meeting to end the strikes crippling the
country
mr speaker
it's armed forces we
under this prime minister those serving
our country are facing a real terms tax
pay cut
why is his government more focused on
increasing bank
or order or order mr mcneil
your voice isn't quiet it's like mine it
carries so the best thing to do if you
want it to curry try standing on the
tourist for a while
mr speaker it's armed forces week
under this prime minister those serving
our country are facing a real terms pay
cut
why is his government more focused on
increasing bankers pay than the pay of
those that are running the country
how how absolutely satirical that he
should talk about our support for the
armed forces and when we've increased
our funding for our armed forces by a
record sum since the end of the cold war
and when eight of the shadow front bench
eight of the shadow front bench actually
wanted to get rid of our nuclear
deterrent
including the shadow foreign secretary
we're helping people yes it's true maybe
it's true
mr speaker we are helping people up and
down the country 1200 pounds will be
coming into into their bank accounts of
the 8 million most vulnerable households
they're cutting national insurance and
will be coming into their bank account
as a as a result of the steps and my
right honorable federation but what
we're also doing is reforming our
systems so we cut costs for people up
and down reforming
our energy markets building a nuclear
reactor every year rather than one every
ten years mr speaker uh getting people
off welfare into work half a million
people off welfare into work because we
cut the cut the time people were waiting
on benefits mr dicker and cutting the
cost of transport for working people mr
speaker by delivering reforms while
they're out on the out on the picket
line
out on the picket line literally holding
hands with arthur's scargill mr speaker
that's then it's worse than under jeremy
corbyn
this is a government that is taking this
country forward they would take it back
to the
much mr 1970s
for years in harrogate to nursery we had
the labor no growth northern rail
franchise we now have new rolling stock
more and better services yeah
yeah we have those seen some lost as the
industries have to suspend some services
while they catch up on driver training
loss during the pandemic strikes just
takes us back to the 1970s
so will the prime minister's focus on
the future ensure that we have
apprenticeship schemes
focusing for on engineering and driver
training to ensure that we've recovered
the services lost we have an industry
that's focused upon efficiency and
embraces technology for the future yeah
my my right home offenders knows exactly
what he speaks and where uh we're we're
doing just that we're reforming train
driver training to make entry into the
uh sector simpler whilst continuing of
course uh to make sure that we meet
vital safety requirements
we now come to leader the s p in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself can i associate myself with the
remarks of the prime minister and the
leader of the labour party as we mark
armed services we can thank all our
service personnel for the services that
they give mr speaker on win rush day we
celebrate all those who have made
scotland and the uk their home my party
backs calls for a major commemoration
for the 75th anniversary next year so we
can properly mark the value contribution
that those that came here have made
mr speaker this morning it was revealed
that uk inflation is now at a 40-year
high
families right across these islands are
seeing their income squeezed as prices
rise bills soar and tory cuts in tax
hikes hammer home
after 12 years in government the tories
have left the uk economy in the doldrums
and pushed millions of people into
poverty
so can i ask the prime minister
does he think his government bears any
blame for the fact that the united
kingdom is doing so much worse than our
european neighbours
actually mr speaker i think the whole
house knows and the whole country knows
we've got a global inflationary problem
but this government has the uh the
fiscal firepower to deal with it uh mr
speaker and that is i think of benefit
to the whole of the united kingdom
including uh scotland as we've seen uh
throughout the uh pandemic and there's i
think it's a matter of fact that taxes
are actually highest of all uh in
scotland mr speaker
well actually that is that is not true
mr speaker but of course the prime
minister the prime minister can make all
the excuses he likes but the fact is the
uk economy is lagging behind on his
watch actually if he looks at france
inflation is less than six percent there
this morning's report from the
resolution foundation and the london
school of economics is the latest in a
string of devastating reports on the
outlook for the uk economy the report
could not be clearer the tory
government's disastrous brexit is
driving wages down
pushing inflation
and will make us further over the next
decade but instead of reversing course
the prime minister is recklessly
threatening a trade war at the worst
possible time will he finally come to
his senses and negotiate in economic
agreement with the eu or is he going to
willfully willfully push the uk into a
recession
uh mr speaker that nobody wants a a
trade war nor is there any need for one
but i think he's absolutely i'm afraid
he's underestimating what this country
is currently achieving not just the
modern investment but a record venture
capital investment in this country uh
which has now overtaken
china mr speaker as a venue for a
venture capital investment and not to
say nothing about what we're getting in
tech and that of course mr speaker uh
the benefits of that are being felt
throughout the whole of the united
kingdom
thank you mr speaker i very much support
the work of this government to level up
all parts of the united kingdom
constituency in the scottish borders but
the scottish borders improved transport
connectivity is the key to leveling up
so the prime minister we confirm his
government's support for improvements to
the cross-border a1 road and also the
feasibility study to extend the borders
railway to hoyt newcastleton and on to
carlisle
thank you for an excellent piece of
lobbying and i can tell him that we are
we're looking at certainly the
department of transport is working with
transport scotland on the possible
extension of the borders railway to to
carlisle and on the a1 a decision uh is
to be made later this year
caroline luke
thank you very much mr speaker it's
emerged that there is a backlog of 23
000 applications under the afghan
relocation and assistance policy with
just two of 3 000 applications for
refuge by afghans who worked for britain
processed since april yet at the same
time staff working on the arab scheme
have been slashed by a quarter since
december this is an incredible betrayal
of the afghan people who put their lives
on the line to work for our country so i
still have casework many people from the
cheevening alumni for example who've
been promised support since september
can i send those cases to him will he
put more resources into the uh scheme
and will he lift the cap on the acrs
scheme so that we can finally do our
best for the people of afghanistan
i thank her very much but i think i'm
afraid that she is
underestimating what this country is
already doing for the people of
afghanistan and i think
our armed forces day we should celebrate
our pitting that brought fifteen
thousand out i and i've uh i'm
of course i'm of course very happy to
look at the cases that she uh that she
wants to raise and we will do our best
for them and for their families mr
speaker but this house should be in no
doubt of the of the generous welcome
that we continue to give to people from
syria from afghanistan uh from ukraine
uh from hong kong we have a record to be
very proud of
andy carter
thank you very much mr speaker my
constituents in chapelford in penketh in
great sankey and in appleton all tell me
they want to see more police officers
tackling issues like anti-social
behavior
tackling issues like domestic abuse and
burglary and thanks to the initiatives
of john dwyer the excellent police and
crime commissioner in cheshire
and sustained recruitment by the new
chief constable the hard work of our
police officers is paying off with
almost a 50 increase in arrests for
domestic abuse in cheshire over the last
12 months compared to the last 12 months
can my right honourable friend update
the house on how many more officers have
been recruited in both cheshire and
across the uk since he became the prime
minister and will he join me in
recognizing this
can i can i just can i can i just say
other members do want to get in the
longer the quest and the less he'll get
in your friendship will dwindle if you
carry on like that prime minister
mr speak i could tell him very very
briefly uh it's 30 576 more police
officers 200 more in cheshire mr speaker
but what they're also doing mr speaker
is they're cutting neighborhood crime
already by 31 our streets are getting
safer as a result
thank you a clear majority of members of
the northern ireland assembly reject the
government's protocol bill on the prime
minister's rationale for it
and businesses fear its consequences
this prime minister has been clear on
multiple occasions his commitment so
called to the all all aspects of the
good friday agreement in census that
includes the european convention on
human rights being part of domestic law
so how can he stand over that commitment
when the justice secretary is about to
publish a bill that unpicks and
disapplies the human rights act within
our domestic law he can't have it both
ways
i think if the uh honorable gentleman
will just wait for the justice
secretary's statement which follows
shortly i think he will find that he is
in arrow in what he's just said
alexander stafford thank you mr speaker
high wage high skill jobs at the heart
of my campaign to level up rother valley
and tackle the cost of living crisis
i have personally hosted two job fairs
and thanks to 11 million pound
investment for the government's leveling
up fund rother valley will benefit from
a cutting-edge skills and employment
village and a leading incubator space
for creating apprenticeships and
startups host to the old maltby grammar
school staff areas were neglected under
labour in light of this will my right on
warframe the prime minister pledge his
support for highways high school roller
valley level up our high streets and
also visit roller valley to see
levelling up in action
yes but i think probably the best member
for robert valley that we've ever had
mr speaker and i thank you very much and
we're going to continue with our agenda
of leveling up across the whole country
uh through all the difficulties that
this country has has faced and it will
get a young people uh across the country
and in rother valley into good jobs uh
for generations to come and that is our
ambition it's also speaker tens of
thousands of people were marching
through london last weekend protesting
against this out of touch government
rail workers are on strike royal mail
workers nhs workers teachers and even
barristers are on the verge of taking
industrial action
all workers are struggling to cope with
the worst cost of living crisis in
history
ministers are planning to boost city
bosses pay whilst demanding wages
for everyone else so can the prime
minister tell me when is he going to
stop meaningless sound bites and instead
start supporting working people across
our country
if she if she wants to support the
working people of this country mr
speaker can i suggest she gets off the
picket line
and supports the track and support and
has a word with her leader mr speaker it
supports the traveling public of this
country who want to see a reduction in
their cost of transport which this
government is delivering
thank you mr speaker for much of britain
leveling up means the revitalization of
british industry and the jobs that goes
with it many countries around the world
such as germany and china get a
competitive advantage by burning lignite
the dirtiest form of fossil fuel so does
my uh roger and friend share my concerns
about the ethics of holding back british
industry and exporting and magnifying
our carbon emissions overseas
uh all in the name of net zero
mr speaker i think we can we can all be
proud of the way we've reduced uh co2
emissions in this country but plainly it
makes no sense uh to be uh importing
coal particularly for uh metallurgical
uh purposes uh when we have our own
domestic resources
louie fletcher
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
knows that we in coventry and
warwickshire are proudly the uk's
leading center for battery vehicle
innovation
he knows because he visited
[Applause]
he knows because he visited the uk
battery industrialization center just
last year
if this government wants this vital
sector to survive for the future the
prime minister needs to confirm his
support
will he give a concrete guarantee for
the resources needed for the west
midlands gigafactory project to go ahead
so we can deliver much needed skilled
jobs in coventry for
2025. yeah
well mr speaker that's probably the
first sensible question from the
opposition ventures and i can tell her
i can tell that that we do actively
support uh gigafactories because i
believe they can be of huge advantages
uh huge advantage for the uk economy
that's why i'm proud to see one now in
blithe uh we're working with the
authorities in the in the west midlands
in coventry uh to make sure that we also
get a successful result there
[Music]
sir bill wiggin
harriford sixth form college has over
600 students who rely on the trains to
get them to their exams this week what
can my right honourable friend do to
ensure that these young people doing
their gcses and a levels are not
punished by the train strikers
well mr speaker i know how much my my
right honorable friend cares for uh
students and
in his constituency and i can tell him
uh that no exams have been cancelled as
a result of the strikes so far we expect
schools and colleges to have contingency
arrangements in place to manage uh
disruption if students arrive late then
schools should allow them to take the
paper and exam boards will determine if
that paper can be marked based on how
late the student is and i've told it mr
speaker if the student misses the exam
completely the school can apply for
their grades to be calculated from the
other assessments they have completed in
that subject and i hope uh that is
helpful to my run or more friends
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
will be aware of the problems that arose
in the in paris at the european cup
final
will he agree with me that both the
french
you for authorities attempts to blame
liverpool fans for the failure to keep
order
uh at the stadium has been
comprehensively disproven
here and will he ensure that the french
failure to police the event is roundly
condemned
i thank him very much mr speaker i think
the whole house will have seen uh how
those initial accounts of what took
place were completely debunked uh and
proved to be incorrect in respect of the
liverpool fans and i think it was right
uh that the french authorities and i
think uefa issued a full apology of what
took place
so desmond swaid
[Applause]
back control is to apply to the echr too
isn't it
mr speaker i think you should wait uh
for my right honourable friend the
deputy prime minister will be saying a
little bit about that in just a moment
but i can tell him that when it comes to
uh the rwanda uh policy that we are
pursuing that policy mr speaker has not
been ruled unlawful by any uk court nor
so far by any international court mr
speaker and we will continue with that
policy
much mr speaker
the father-in-law of my constituent
ibrahim is a former supreme court judge
in afghanistan
he successfully prosecuted and put
behind bars
hundreds of terrorists associated with
the taliban al-qaeda and isis
seven months on since he put in his arab
application there is no progress he's
living in hiding his only option is a
perilous journey to pakistan where if
his visa is refused he will be deported
back into the hands of the taliban
so will the prime minister meet with me
and the former judge's family to see how
we can save the life of a man who i have
no doubt has helped save hundreds of
british lives
well can i thank her very much for
raising that particular case and it does
sound uh extremely uh meritorious and
i'll make sure that she uh she gets a
meeting with uh the department of
defense that runs uh arap uh mr speaker
that we do our best to expedite that
application as fast as we can
to ben
[Music]
thank you mr speaker i'm proud to
represent over a thousand park home
residents
when will the government address the
injustice of pitch fees determined by
rpi and how is the government going to
ensure they can all benefit from the
energy grant yeah yeah
i i thank the honorable uh jennifer my
honorable friend we are going to
introduce legislation as soon as
parliamentary time allows to uh change
the inflationary index used in
calculating the annual pitch fee uh to
uh to cpi uh mr speaker and i'm told
that the department of liberty up and
housing has undertaken research on the
impacts on residents and site owners of
a change to the 10
commission that is currently paid uh on
the sale of a park home caroline harris
thank you mr speaker i'm sure the prime
minister is as thrilled as i am that you
mr speaker signed the well-being of what
women menopause pledged last week to
show support for women in this place so
will the prime minister follow mr
speaker's example and show with a better
access to treatment for women in england
by introducing the single alibaba annual
payment for hrt now not make them wait
till april 23 a full 18 months after it
was first promised
i thank her very much for raising what i
is a very important issue that one that
is understood keenly on all sides of
this house and i i know that my right
honourable friend the health secretary
is accelerating the work of the hrt uh
task force to give uh people to give uh
people up and down the country the
reassurance and the treatment that they
need no question dean russell
thank you mr speaker
thank you mr speaker i was incredibly
grateful that the prime minister
launched my initiative to train a
thousand mental health first aiders
in awareness in watford over a year and
a half ago and it's been successfully
delivered by watford and west arch
chamber of commerce and many amazing
volunteers so i know he understands the
importance of mental wellbeing and
mental health sadly bullying can have a
long-lasting effect on mental health and
well-being so today the diana award are
raising awareness about bullying in
schools and online and with the don't
face it alone campaign so we'll be prime
minister please join me in encouraging
any young person experiencing bullying
to speak up and speak out
kai thank you very much and to
congratulate him on his
own campaign on this issue i think
everybody understands that bullying is
an absolutely appalling
experience and something that we should
not tolerate in our society and i'm
delighted to see so many colleagues so
many honourable members wearing uh their
blue ribbons today mr speaker we should
all speak out against bullying but we
should also make sure that we give
everybody the courage and to speak out
against bullying as well
that ends pmq's those who wish to leave
please do
well prime minister's questions there a
range of questions to the prime minister
from whether or not he had sought
employment for uh carrie now carrie
johnson uh his now wife uh also
questions about strikes uh human rights
legislation let's bring in
our deputy political correspondent sam
coates our deputy political editor in
fact and sam kierstama uh always
shouting at the prime minister at one
point get on with your job but did he
did he land any real punches today
um i thought it was a better performance
by kierstarma than sometimes you got
from the labour leader he
i mean essentially boris johnson was in
a bit of trouble in this prime
minister's questions from the first
question when labour mp chris elmore uh
asked boris johnson uh have you ever
considered the appointment of your
current spouse to any government poison
to any organization in one of the royal
households now viewers may be aware of
the stories about uh both of those
things allegedly happening in the last
few days now there have been denials
about both of those stories given to the
press
but of course
when it comes to what the prime minister
says at the dispatch box uh he is held
to perhaps a higher standard
of uh veracity than uh government spin
doctors when trying to kill an awkward
story uh and i think that uh boris
johnson's uh decision to sidestep uh
that question effectively not do what he
could have done which is to give an
explicit denial uh to one or both uh of
those two allegations will be picked up
as it was by kierstama almost
immediately after it doesn't mean the
stories are true
but boris johnson had a moment where he
could have denied them and he chose not
to do that
and i think that kirstama started his
questions
by referencing that and the wakefield
by-election which along with the
tiverton one is taking place uh tomorrow
uh before trying to
push back at what he anticipated was
gonna be quite difficult uh questions on
strikes and points on strikes from
okay let's listen in dominic rob justice
secretary's talking now about human
rights legislation only kept within the
trammells of what had gone out in the
consultation document but i heed his
advice as ever
and with your permission i will make a
statement on the publication and
introduction of a uk bill of rights as
we take the next steps to fulfill our
manifesto commitment and deliver human
rights reform across the country
mr speaker we have a proud tradition of
freedom under the rule of law in this
country and i would remind honourable
members on all sides that it dates back
centuries to magna carta not just 1998.
the bill of rights is the next chapter
in the evolution and the strengthening
of our human rights framework it's
published today and available online and
i believe in the vote office
mr speaker let me turn to the key
strands of our reforms
first and again to remind the house as i
said when we launched the consultation
back in december the uk intends to
remain a state party to the european
convention on human rights
it is a common sense set of principles
and the problems that we have
encountered have stemmed from the
elastic interpretations and the
expansion absent meaningful democratic
oversight in particular as a result of
the procedural framework set out in the
human rights act
and so mr speaker our key objectives
with reform
are to reinforce
those quintessentially uk-wide rights
like freedom of speech the liberty that
guards all of the others
and we will also recognize the role of
jury trial mindful of how it operates in
different parts of the united kingdom
and something which is not prevalent on
the continent but is very much part of
the heritage and the pedigree of this
country
these liberties are part of our proud
history but they're also critical to
strengthening our place in the world as
an open vibrant and rambunctious
democracy
mr speaker next we will strengthen the
separation of powers in this country
affirming the supremacy of the supreme
court being explicit that the uk courts
are under no obligation to follow the
strasbourg case law and indeed are free
to diverge from it
i'm proud of our world beating judiciary
and what else is the point
what else is the point of a supreme
court
if it bows insubordination to a european
one
mr speaker we've also seen the goal
posts on human rights shift over time
through expansive judicial
interpretations licensed by the human
rights act which has tended to magnify
overweening rulings from strasbourg
although it is worth noting in fairness
that there has been more judicial
restraint in strasbourg
on occasion in recent times nevertheless
mr speaker what ebbs may flow
and we will ensure in our bill of rights
that any expansion of human rights law
as opposed to its interpretation is
subject to proper democratic oversight
by elected members in this house
our reforms in particular to sections
two and three of the human rights act
will squarely address those flaws in the
current framework
and we'll also be
crystal clear that when it comes to the
laws of the land and the legitimate
necessity uh necessary and constructive
dialogue that we have with strasbourg it
is parliament that has the last word
there's been much said by the judiciary
in strasbourg about an age of
subsidiarity with greater respect for
the will of domestic democratic
institutions particularly since the 2012
brighton declaration that the uk is very
much spearheading to uh promote reform
our approach is crafted very much with
that in mind to facilitate that dialogue
between the united kingdom and
strasbourg and avail ourselves of the
margin of appreciation which is uh
within the bounds of the convention
equally as a matter of basic democratic
principle will we will reaffirm and
reinforce the democratic oversight and
control exercised by this house
now mr speaker our bill of rights sets
out a range of important reforms a
permission stage and the uk courts to
assert greater checks over frivolous
claims at an earlier stage that of
course reflects the strasbourg court
itself which has an admissibility stage
we've included provision to ensure that
behavior of anyone claiming a breach of
their human rights is taken into account
when our courts consider compensation
it's a principle of
of law in this country that those who
come to equity do so with clean hands i
think that should be reflected in human
rights claims as well
we will also expressly mr speaker
provide for greater weight to be given
to parliament's determination of the
public interest set out in primary
legislation when considering the
interpretation of rights to ensure we
are better equipped to protect the
public and that will reinforce our
ability to for example
deport more foreign national offenders
and in particular
those claiming ever more elastic
interpretations of article 8 and the
right to family like life to frustrate
the deportation process
it will also ensure we can deliver our
reforms to the parole system so when it
comes to those finely balanced
assessments of risk
in decisions on the release of
potentially dangerous offenders public
protection is the overriding priority
our bill of rights will also mean
that we can prevent well-meaning but
counterproductive and onerous straight
jacket regulatory burdens being placed
on our public services resulting from
rulings determined by lawyers in court
rather on such sensitive matters being
set by elected lawmakers in this house
that's particularly important mr speaker
with respect to finely balanced
assessments of social policy matters
with financial impact the bread and
butter issues
that it is for this parliament to decide
mr speaker we have consulted and engaged
very widely across the whole of the
united kingdom we will continue to do so
this is a uk-wide reform but we want to
work with all of the devolved
administrations on these essential
reforms so we will be seeking
legislative consent motions noting
nevertheless that the status of the
human rights act is as a and i quote
protected enactment under the devolved
settlements so uh reform replacement
revision can only take place from
westminster mr speaker our bill of
rights will strengthen our proud
tradition of freedom it will demarcate a
clearer separation of powers it will
ensure greater respect for our
democratic institutions and it will
better protect the public and restore a
healthy dose of common sense the justice
system which is essential for commanding
public confidence
ultimately it will make us freer it will
help keep our streets safer and i
commend this statement to the house
i now call the shadow minister ellie
reeves
[Music]
thank you mr speaker and i'm sure the
whole house will want to join me in
sending our deepest condolences to my
honorable friend the member for croydon
north who following the death of his
father last week cannot be here today
mr speaker this is a very dark day for
victims of crime for women for people in
care for everyone in this country who
rely on the state to protect them from
harm
this is not a bill of rights it's a con
the lord chancellor knows this because
he's been working on it for over a
decade we know from the queen's speech
that this bill will take away the duty
of the state to protect everyone from
harm by removing the positive
obligations set out in the human rights
act
it will force victims of crime seeking
justice to schlep to strasbourg creating
endless delays and red tape
sir peter gross and the review panel
doesn't think the human rights act
undermines parliamentary sovereignty or
that the uk courts are undermined by the
european court so why proceed with this
bill in the first place
it's because this is a government that
looks to pick a fight to cover up its
own failures and then finds someone else
to blame
we've seen a succession of conservative
members do this in the form of blaming
the european court to deflect from their
bungled and unworkable asylum policy
some shamefully have even demanded that
the uk withdraws altogether from the
european convention of human rights
for members of the party of churchill
who inspired the european convention of
human rights to want to do away with it
all together is really quite something
i gather that he doesn't want to
withdraw from the european convention
not least because he knows it would
fatally undermine the good friday
agreement and peace in northern ireland
so will he now condemn members of his
own party who have made this dangerous
and reckless demands
mr speaker we on this side of the house
are proud of the gift that churchill
gave to the world in the universal
declaration and in the european
convention that followed
but we are proud of still that it was a
labour government in 1998 that brought
rights home from strasbourg
the human rights act is held up around
the world as an exemplar of modern human
rights legislation
which is why the european court very
rarely overrules our judges something
that the review panel recognized in
their report
it is a beacon of hope to people in
countries whose basic human rights are
trampled over by strong men and
dictators
and there is no better example right now
than in ukraine where the rights of
millions are being crushed under the
jack boots of vladimir putin
what stunning hypocrisy from this
government to preach to others about the
importance of defending rights abroad
while snatching british people's rights
away at home
this is a government gimmick by a party
which seeks headlines for botched
policies and then blames others when it
fails
the answer to fixing the mess this
conservative government has made of the
immigration and asylum system isn't to
take away british people's rights given
to them by the human rights act the
human rights act has allowed people to
object when doctors put do not
resuscitate orders on their beds without
their consent
it's allowed people with learning
disabilities imprisoned in locked units
to be reunited with their families
it's allowed families of major disasters
like manchester or hillsborough to seek
justice where public bodies have let
them down
it's allowed elderly married couples in
residential care to object when care
home managers try to separate them and
it's allowed victims of rapists like
john warboys from forcing the police to
investigate cases of rape
mr speaker this bill of rights con isn't
just an attack on victims of crime who
the state has failed to protect it's an
attack on women
women have used the human rights act to
challenge the police when they've either
failed or refused to investigate rape
and sexual assault cases
we saw it in the case of john warboys
who is thought to have assaulted over
150 women
it should come as no surprise that this
bill has been put forward by a
conservative government that has
effectively decriminalized rape
last
last week's last week's scorecards
last week's scorecard show pitiful
progress on the record low
some people who wanted to catch my eye
they won't catch you by shooting
somebody's speaking
last week's scorecard showed pitiful
progress on the record low rate
convictions under this government the
typical weight for cases to complete in
court has reached three years and a
fifth have seen weights of four years
and that's if the case even gets to
court the number of rape trials
postponed in our crown court a day's
notice has risen fourfold
it's no wonder that rape survivors are
dropping out of their cases in droves
so will victims even bother to report
their case at all when they learn his
bill of rights will stop them from
forcing our under-resourced police to
investigate
it says everything about a lord
chancellor and a government that is soft
on rape soft on rapists and hard on
survivors that they want to take away
the final backstop available to victims
to get justice
women will be in no doubt this is a
government that lets off rapists and let
survivors down and today is the proof mr
speaker this bill will see enormous
amounts of red tape for victims of crime
seeking justice it's an attack on women
it undermines peace in northern ireland
it's the hallmark of a party out of
ideas that can no longer govern
[Applause]
there are times given well there we've
heard from the justice secretary dominic
robb and a shadow dominic robb talking
about a new bill of rights which is
being published today it will replace
the 1998 human rights act
he says that it will allow uk courts to
not always have to follow case law of
the european court of human rights some
courts have interpreted the law as a
duty to follow these findings when
actually it is simply a case that they
should just take account he says it will
make it easier to deport foreign
criminals of course many objections from
the labour party say it will also lead
to lots of other losses of human rights
for other organizations let's bring in
our deputy political editor sam coates
and sam
a bit of a ticking off for dominic raab
as well just beforehand by the speaker
because of course once again the
government announced this in the media
before telling the house yes which
thankfully allows us to uh get our heads
around what is a pretty significant
pretty complex pretty important uh piece
of legislation being introduced by
ministers today uh just by way of
background for the last 70 years the uk
has signed up to the european convention
of human rights which provides a kind of
broad framework um uh above british
courts that people could appeal to
there's a strasbourg court that you have
been able to
appeal to if you thought that one of
those
principles one of those convention
rights is being abused by
the british government or one of the
public bodies
and it's that and the relationship
between the uk courts and that 70 year
old convention that's coming under the
microscope today now uh the the
principles uh laid down in law by the
strasbourg court have increasingly been
irritating ministers uh through the last
decade there was a long-running row
about whether or not prisoners could get
the vote it was seen as a breach of
their uh human rights under the
convention
and that's really when this issue of
just how closely british courts were
following strasbourg rulings
came under the spotlight dominic rabb
all the way through this period
following this debate uh pretty closely
pretty much on top of this ever since he
became an mp in 2010.
his proposal today is not that the
united kingdom immediately withdraws
from the convention
and stops following the rulings all of
the directives of the strasbourg court
but what it does do is it loosens the
relationship between the two as you were
saying what dominic raab's legislation
does is it rips up uh the way that new
labour uh implemented the uh human
rights act it gets rid of the human
rights act uh which forced uh all of the
kind of interim measures and case law
from strasbourg uh to be uh taken
account when the uk courts are coming uh
to their decisions uh and instead uh
suggests that supreme court uh and
british law will will remain supreme uh
there is no longer an obligation uh once
this legislation is passed uh on the
british government to follow the interim
uh decisions by strasbourg now an
example of an interim decision was the
interim decision by the strasbourg court
last week to block the flight to rwanda
containing potential asylum seekers uh
there are uh decisions that have um that
have until now or currently have
immediate binding force uh dominick
rabbs wants to make it clear that you no
longer have to follow
uh the strasbourg rulings immediately uh
when they do one of these kind of
interim uh decisions now uh ministers
like dominic robert paines to say none
of this means that will be ejected from
this human rights framework others
believe that in time if britain
continues to defy
human rights court uh judgment interim
or other uh that's the destination that
we'll end at i think we're just going to
see have to see how this legislation
progresses through parliament and then
what it is impact really is before we
know whether or not we're going to stay
in this uh framework of human rights for
the long term
okay sam thanks very much
well let's bring you some breaking news
now a report by the police watchdog has
found that rotherham police thought
sexually exploited children were
complicit in their abuse the
investigation by the independent office
for police conduct published in the last
hour looked at alleged police misconduct
linked to the rotherham abuse scandal
between 1997 and 2013.
sky's becky cottrell has more she's in
wakefield in west yorkshire and becky
just looking through some of the facts
of this um children as young as 11 being
failed to remove from the company of
older men
yeah it's really tragic to hear what
this report does is it really lays out
the culture of south yorkshire police at
that time the iopc director the police
watchdog today said that these children
weren't viewed as victims i spoke to the
deputy chief constable at south
yorkshire police and he put it even more
shockingly he said that vulnerable
children were not viewed as children
which is kind of unbelievable to hear
now but that is simply the way it was in
many instances and that is why you would
have police officers finding these
children like you said as young as 11 in
cars or in houses with older men that we
now know were abusing them and they
simply didn't do anything to intervene
and in many cases the girls would say oh
this is my boyfriend and the police
would accept that and leave them and we
can assume that that led to many more
children being abused now the the
details and the scale of abuse in
rotherham that is not particularly new
we we knew the details of that because
it was a very comprehensive report back
in 2014 by alexis j but what we had been
waiting for and it's taken eight years
was this report from the police watchdog
to find out not just the role of
individual officers but what has
happened to them subsequently now the
watchdog investigated 47 officers and 14
of them were found to have a case to
answer for either misconduct or gross
misconduct
that no one was sacked and the most
severe punishment was a final written
warning and in many cases the officers
had resigned and could no longer face
disciplinary proceedings now i spoke to
a survivor of abuse in rotherham
yesterday sammy woodhouse she's
campaigned for years on this issue and
she was disgusted that no one had been
dismissed she said in many cases it
feels like officers have been rewarded
being able to retire and get their
pensions while survivors of this abuse
are still dealing with the emotional and
in some cases physical fallout of what
they suffered now south yorkshire police
have apologized they say the force is
very different today but they still need
to work to build trust with this
community so survivors can come forward
and they can try and stem this awful
crime of child sexual exploitation
becky cottrell thank you very much
this is sky news coming up next we're
returning to the cost of living crisis
as it is squeezing harder inflation is
rising to a 40-year high what does that
mean for all of us what does it mean in
terms of pay rises the cost of food and
how much money we may or may not have in
our pockets also looking at the impact
on pensions as well all of that to come
after this break in sky news at one
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon you're watching sky news
at one the headlines inflation hits a
fresh 40-year high up 9.1 percent as
rising fuel and food prices worse than
the cost of living squeeze
all he's interested in doing is blaming
everyone else
can't he hear the country screaming at
him get on with your job
[Applause]
afghanistan earthquake at least a
thousand people now killed and over one
and a half thousand injured as the
country is hit by a major quake
pushing to ignore the deputy prime
minister and his bid to prevent the uk
listening to the court that blocked the
rwanda removal flights
windrush remembered the official
unveiling of a national monument in
central london
and glastonbury is back the festival
finally celebrates its 50th with the
oldest and youngest headliners ever to
mark its return
[Music]
hello good afternoon the squeeze on
families across the uk has got a little
tighter as the rate of inflation hits a
40-year high the consumer prices index
rose slightly to 9.1 percent in the year
to may that's up from 9 in april the
rise comes as the bank of england is
warning that inflation will reach 11
percent this year putting further
pressure on the chancellor
while there was a heated exchange about
the cost of living crisis between the
prime minister and the labour leader kia
stammer during prime minister's
questions
there's a huge problem facing the
country and all he's interested in doing
is blaming everyone else
can't he hear the country screaming at
him get on with your job
whilst he blames everyone and anyone
working people are paying the price
this week his treasury minister said
there's a society-wide responsibility
for people to take a pay cut
at the same time his chief of staff is
trying to change the law to get bankers
bonuses increased
so come on
come on
only one of them could be right is it
his treasury minister who says every
worker needs a pay cut or is it his
chief of staff who says every banker
needs a pay rise
actually mr speaker there's government
five million public sector pay
apartments have to work is getting a pay
rise mr speaker we've increased the
living wage by a thousand pounds uh
we've increased universal credit so that
people get a thousand pounds more
thanks to the fiscal firepower that we
have mr speaker we're putting 1200
pounds more into every one of the eight
million most vulnerable households in
the country that is what we can do
because of the tough decisions uh that
we have taken mr speaker but meantime
what we're also trying to do is cut the
cost of transport which is a big part of
people's weekly outgoings by reforming
our railways that's what we're trying to
do but he's standing with the strikers
mr speaker and lifting the cost of
transport for everybody that's the
reality
well we're joined now by a deputy
political editor sam coates i'm a week
of strikes but also a weak worth cost of
living once again high on the agenda
that's right 9.1 inflation according to
the ons this morning i think is going to
dominate political life uh for some
weeks to come the way it's dominating
this week uh is the link to strikes now
ministers use high inflation as one of
the reasons why they can't just give big
pay rewards pay rises uh to striking
rail workers of course there's a whole
series of other
pay deals coming down the track uh even
before the summer recess with the pay
review bodies releasing reports about uh
teachers and police officers and nurses
so if they give in on the strikes that
are taking place at the moment and give
seven eight nine percent pay increases
uh to those rail workers then they'll be
pressured to do the same
and boris johnson really trying to hold
the line at the moment not to
stoke inflation what kierstan was trying
to do is draw a contrast between the
position on the rail workers and some of
the other decisions he highlighted a
leaked correspondence that appeared in
the eye newspaper journalist paul war
revealed on monday where it revealed
that essentially the government is
pushing ahead loosening some of the
restrictions uh over city bonus schemes
uh and that me that will effectively
mean that some of those at the top end
of the income scale could stand to
benefit in the years to come just to the
point where most of the country is
getting below inflation pay increases
meaning that they are suffering a real
terms drop in their uh wages so kirsten
are trying to push ahead with that
whilst also scoring political points uh
on the subject of the wakefield
by-election uh where the conservative
local party isn't entirely behind the
local candidate uh but also
what you have is a situation been
rumbling for the last couple of days
allegations that carrie johnson uh boris
johnson's wife was before they were
married uh possibly in line or boris
johnson was trying to get her a job
first of all in the foreign office that
was reported briefly in the times on
friday or uh and then the times uh
effectively pulled that story uh and
then there was a
uh a report in the telegraph this
morning uh that there was an attempt to
get uh carrie johnson a job in the royal
household or uh working alongside the
royal household that too uh was denied
but boris johnson asked about both of
those by a labour mp at the start of
prime minister's questions and a denial
came there none let's hear that exchange
prime minister
have has he ever considered the
appointment
of his current spouse
to a government post or to any
organization yes in one of the royal
households be honest prime minister yes
or no yes or no
mr speaker i i know why the
uh the party opposite wants to talk
about uh non-existent jobs uh in the in
the media mr speaker because they don't
want to talk about what's going on in
the real
world i'm proud to say i'm proud to say
actually uh that we now have
620 000 uh people more in payroll
employment than before the pandemic
began which would never have been
possible if we listened to the right on
the normal opposite
quite stark isn't it sound that the
prime minister was given that
opportunity to either deny it and he
just
gave an entirely different answer and
dominic raab also up in the house after
the prime minister new bill of rights
that's right this in theory politically
is a little bit of red meat for
conservative backbenchers concerned
about just how important these
strasbourg court and the european
convention of human rights which britain
has been signed up to for about 70 years
has become in determining uh what uk
courts and uk ministers can and can't do
effectively what dominic raab's
announcing today is it's going to rip up
the human rights act which labour
introduced which tied british courts
quite closely to what was happening over
in strasbourg and instead create a kind
of
looser arrangement where
the courts and ministers no longer have
to automatically follow
strasbourg case law it means that you no
longer have to uk ministers no longer
have to follow interim decisions like
the one uh to block the rwanda flight uh
next last week and this really takes
britain on a slightly different path
it could ultimately result in britain
being ejected from the european uh
convention in human rights but i think
we're quite a long way away from that
and ministers deny that's either the aim
or would be the consequence of this
piece of legislation but what it does do
in the words of ministers uh tougher
than the courts the british court's
ability uh to be supreme and minister's
ability uh to act labor says it erodes
the kind of human rights that many
particularly women have relied on for
the last few decades
sam
our bill of rights will strengthen our
proud tradition of freedom it will
demarcate a clearer separation of powers
it will ensure greater respect for our
democratic institutions and it will
better protect the public and restore a
healthy dose of common sense to the
justice system which is essential for
commanding public confidence
ultimately it will make us freer it will
help keep our streets safer and i
commend this statement to the house
bill will have a choppy time both in the
house of commons but also in particular
in the house of lords where there are
many legal experts the future
destination of quite britain's
relationship with human rights uh
frameworks with the strasbourg court
with the european convention i think is
still uncertain sam thanks very much
well returning to the cost of living and
fuel prices have continued to rise today
let's look at the latest figures
especially important as disruption from
the rail strikes continue well the
latest figures show the average price of
petrol has gone up once again hitting
another new record of 189.33
pence getting closer and closer to two
pounds
and it's a similar story for diesel with
the average price hit